dans quelques semaines je fais très mes
quatre ans et ma naissance est
matérialisée par une question grandement
existentielle à laquelle je n'ai
toujours pas de réponse formelle
qu'est-ce qui explique que sur deux
personnes vivant un événement difficile
une va le vivre de manière traumatique
alors que l'autre en fera quelque chose
de beau voir exceptionnel
comment expliquer que Nelson Mandela
ayant passé 27 années de sa vie en
prison en ressortent non pas avec
l'envie de détruire ce lui ayant infligé
ça mais avec l'idée de rassembler autour
de sa cause
comment expliquer que Boris Cyrulnik qui
a vu sa famille se faire tuer massacrer
alors qu'il n'était qu'un enfant pendant
la guerre
a dédié sa vie au concept de résilience
et comment expliquer que Paul Fontaine
qui vit avec une maladie qu'on appelle
la mucoviscidose et 50% de capacité
respiratoires
décide de courir des marathons de gravir
des sommets à 6000 mètres d'altitude
alors que ces médecins lui prédisent que
c'est impossible
ces questions là me fascinent tant parce
que quand je regarde ma vie sincèrement
rien ne me prédestiné à devenir ce que
je suis aujourd'hui
rien ne me prédestiné à faire de grandes
études rien ne me prédestiné à devenir
directeur général d'une entreprise à
seulement 26 ans
rien ne me prédestinait à créer et
diriger une entreprise de coaching et
encore moins de choses me prédestinées à
prendre la parole devant des dizaines de
personnes comme je le fais aujourd'hui
en fait il y a 10 ans il y a pas
beaucoup de choses que je me serais cru
capable de faire
parce que il y a 10 ans
les conseillers et les profs n'auraient
pas misé un seul euro sur moi
les appréciations sur le bulletin
c'était plus des trucs du genre
Dorian encore passer son année à
bavarder et la complètement gâché
ou des trucs un peu plus virulents comme
en terminale lorsque mon prof principal
va m'écrire sur le bulletin la chose
suivante
au vu des notes et du comportement de
Dorian il va être difficile de
l'orienter l'année prochaine
paradoxal quand on connaît la suite
il y a 10 ans j'étais également
tellement mal à l'aise à l'idée de
parler devant une seule personne que
j'étais incapable de parler sans mettre
la main devant la bouche
et ça ça s'explique par une chose très
simple que vous voyez derrière moi c'est
une malformation de la mâchoire qui
faisait que peu importe l'appareil
d'orthodontie que je portais j'avais les
dents décalées donc vous aurez bien
compris qu'à cette période j'étais plus
proche de faire une affiche des Dents de
la mer que faire une affiche de James
Bond
d'ailleurs j'ai une anecdote à vous
raconter là dessus
il y a 10 ans j'obtiens un rencard avec
une nana alors faut savoir que déjà il y
a 10 ans obtenir un rencard avec une
nana c'est un événement en soi
et pendant ce rangard je vais réussir
une double performance assez
exceptionnelle
la première chose que je vais arriver à
faire
c'est de ne pas arriver à décrocher deux
phrases sans devenir aussi rouge que le
tapis que vous voyez ici
et la deuxième chose que je vais faire
c'est de recevoir le message suivant
juste après le rencard donc la fille va
m'écrire je pense qu'on se reverra pas
je ne compte pas fréquenter un mec qui
passe plus de temps à mater la serveuse
comme regarder moi
en fait là vous êtes en train de vous
dire le mec est irrespectueux lors des
rancas sauf que pas du tout
en fait ce qui s'est passé ce jour-là
c'est que j'étais tellement complexé
j'étais tellement mal à l'aise à l'idée
qu'elle me regarde
de face comme voit sourire qu'à chaque
fois qu'elle me regardait je détournais
le regard et donc elle s'est dit quoi le
mec matelas serveuse
sauf qu'en fait pas du tout
donc ça c'était le type de performance
que j'étais capable de réaliser il y a
10 ans par manque de confiance et à
cette période je me demandais
sincèrement si un jour j'arriverai à
être confiant
donc suite à ça tous ces événements vont
un peu me saouler et donc du coup je
vais commencer à reprendre ma vie en
main je vais reprendre les études je
vais mettre au sport et je vais subir
une opération de la mâchoire qui va
faire que je vais avoir un beau sourire
mais en fait je vais m'apercevoir d'un
truc c'est que malgré le fait que je me
mette à entreprendre des choses malgré
le fait que je commence à me sentir
mieux dans ma peau et bien il me manque
toujours quelque chose
et ce petit quelque chose je vais
comprendre ce que c'est le 28 juin 2018
j'ai introduit cette conférence en vous
disant que dans quelques semaines je
fais très mes quatre ans et en fait
c'est parce que le 28 juin 2018 je vais
avoir le plus gros chamboulement de
toute ma vie ce jour-là je suis en train
de naviguer sur internet et je vais
avoir la chance de tomber sur une
interview assez
dingue dans cette interview le mec qui
fait l'interview fait le tour du monde
en posant la question suivante aux gens
c'est quoi le bonheur pour vous
c'est une question qui paraît très
simple mais qui est à la fois très
complexe pendant l'interview dont je
vous parle la personne qui répond va
mettre 1h30 pour répondre à cette
question je vais mettre à peu près trois
heures trente à la regarder et je vais
énormément pleurer et je crois que je
vais avoir la plus grosse prise de
conscience de toute ma vie parce que
lors de cette interview la personne va
mettre des mots sur 20 ans de ma vie à
la suite de cette de cet événement je
vais avoir une énergie de dingue à ce
moment là on est en juin 2018 et ce qui
va se passer c'est que je suis en train
de rentrer dans une école de commerce
pour faire mon master en alternance donc
faut savoir que faire un master en
alternance c'est pas chose simple de
trouver une entreprise moi pendant mon
Master je vais changer deux fois
d'entreprise parce que j'ai besoin de
donner du sens à ce que je fais
pendant les vacances que j'ai à côté de
mes cours je vais passer toutes mes
vacances à aller me former à ce qui me
passionne depuis toujours à la
psychologie humaine c'est à dire à la
préparation mentale au coaching
professionnel à la programmation de
Roland linguistique le but comprendre
comment ça marche là-haut
à la suite de mes études comme je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure je vais devenir
directeur général d'une entreprise à
seulement 26 ans je vais créer ma boîte
et je vais faire un autre truc qui va
impacter ma vie c'est que je vais aller
rencontrer et interviewer des
personnalités publiques avec le but de
comprendre comment ils ont pu en arriver
là malgré les difficultés
et lors de ce pèlerinage de 4 ans de
quasiment 4 ans je vais faire trois
apprentissages majeurs
le premier apprentissage que je vais
faire
c'est que la colère est un super pouvoir
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que en
psychologie on sait aujourd'hui que la
colère ça provient d'une perception que
face à une situation donnée
il y a quelque chose un cadre des règles
du jeu qui nous correspondent pas et ça
je vais le comprendre encore de manière
encore plus prononcée lorsque je vais
interviewer Paul Pyronnet que vous voyez
juste derrière qui est un monstre de la
formation en France en Programmation
Neuro Linguistique qui a plus de 50
milliards de formation à son actif il va
me dire la chose suivante en interview
privé il va me dire Dorian tu sais tous
les grands leaders de ce monde sont
animés d'une colère
Martin Luther King Gandhi Nelson Mandela
et il va me dire plutôt que de
dévaloriser le monde avec cette colère
plutôt que de détruire ce qu'il y a
autour de il se sert de cette colère
pour construire un monde qui leur
correspond mieux
et foncièrement quand je regarde ma vie
aujourd'hui c'est ce que je mets vertu
de faire
vous voyez tout à l'heure je vous
parlais du fait que j'ai été rejeté
scolairement par les profs et les
conseillers d'orientation c'est la
raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui je suis
en colère contre le système scolaire et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vais
intervenir dans les lycées pour donner
aux jeunes ce que je n'avais pas à
l'époque de la confiance
le fait que j'ai manqué de confiance en
moi d'estime de moi c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai décidé de
créer une boîte de coaching et de
formation pour accompagner les gens
là-dedans et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je prends la parole aujourd'hui
pour donner le message que c'est
possible d'évoluer
donc ça c'est le premier apprentissage
que je vais faire la colère est un super
pouvoir
le deuxième apprentissage que je vais
faire c'est un apprentissage que
j'essaye de m'appliquer tous les jours
dans ma vie et qui je pense peut servir
à beaucoup de personnes dans cette salle
en tout cas toutes les personnes qui
souhaitent évoluer
ça t'apprentissage c'est le suivant
c'est l'apprentissage qui dit que le
processus et bien plus important que le
résultat
alors vous voyez tout à l'heure je vous
ai raconté une anecdote sur le rancart
sur ce fameux rancart qui vous a fait
sourire et rigoler alors dans la
continuité de ce rencard je vais vous
raconter une autre anecdote
quand j'ai 20 ans il faut savoir que
j'ai deux gros complexes le premier
c'est que j'ai les dents complètement
décalé comme vous avez pu le voir tout à
l'heure et le deuxième complexe que j'ai
c'est que je suis incapable d'avoir une
copie
et donc du coup à l'idée de sortir en
boîte va venir ce que tous les mecs
redoutent la première sortie en boîte
alors faut savoir une chose c'est que la
première sortie en boîte pour nous les
mecs c'est vraiment l'occasion de
montrer qui tu es
et montrer qui tu es en tant que mec
c'est montrer que tu es capable de pécho
une nana
et donc du coup forcément à l'idée
d'aller d'aller en boîte ce soir là je
vais me poser la question en boucle de
me dire comment tu vas faire pour pécho
et donc en faisant ça je suis orienter
sur quoi sur le résultat
et à force de me répéter cette question
sans avoir de réponse je vais commencer
à changer la manière de me poser cette
question et je vais me dire plutôt les
mecs qui arrivent à faire ça en boîte
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont plus que moi
à part les dents
et le premier élément de réponse que je
vais avoir si je vais me dire ces
gars-là ils sont confiants
et en poussant un peu plus cette
réflexion je vais me poser la question
suivante et je vais me dire mais si toi
tu étais confiant ça serait comment
et alors là je vais avoir une idée
absolument géniale je vais me dire si
toi tu étais confiant
Thierry allais aborder toutes les nanas
de la boîte
le truc c'est que ce soir là je l'ai
vraiment fait
donc je suis vraiment allé aborder
toutes les boîtes et vous savez le plus
fou là-dedans c'est que ce soir là ça va
plutôt bien marché malgré le fait que
j'avais les dents complètement décalé
que j'avais un peu de bide et que
j'avais très peu de confiance ça a
marché j'ai réussi à choper deux numéros
alors certes là si vous vous faites le
ratio entre le nombre de nana que je
suis allé voir et le nombre de numéros
c'est pas dingue
mais par contre c'est toujours mieux que
95% de la boîte ce soir là en tout cas
des gars de mon âge
et en fait en faisant ça quelques années
plus tard en étudiant la psychologie
j'ai compris que ce soir-là j'avais
matérialisé un concept de neurosciences
sans le savoir
ce concept là c'est le suivant c'est que
face à une situation donnée on a tous
des pensées et des croyances que ces
pensées ses croyances nous font avoir
des émotions que ces émotions nous font
avoir des comportements et que ces
comportements nous font générer des
résultats
donc moi à l'époque vu que je me sentais
pas bien dans ma peau je me disais quoi
que franchement ça marcherait pas pour
moi et donc du coup j'avais je me
sentais dans l'incapacité d'y aller et
donc le résultat c'est que j'avais pas
de copine sauf qu'en repensant un petit
peu
la manière de réfléchir et on me
penchant un peu plus sur le processus
j'ai commencé à changer mes
comportements c'est à dire que je suis
passé du mec qui a complètement peur à
l'idée d'aller aborder quelqu'un ah je
vais toutes les aborder et donc du coup
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'en
changeant mes comportements j'ai
commencé à changer mes résultats c'est à
dire que j'ai obtenu deux numéros
et ce qui est magnifique c'est que quand
vous commencez à changer vos résultats
vous commencez à planter la graine
dans vos pensées vos croyances que la
situation peut être différente la
prochaine fois et donc moi je suis passé
ce jour-là de c'est complètement
impossible pour toi d'avoir une copine à
c'est possible d'avoir des numéros et
donc potentiellement de pouvoir embrayer
donc ça c'est le deuxième apprentissage
que je vais faire que le processus est
plus important que le résultat
le troisième apprentissage que je vais
faire
je pense que honnêtement si j'avais un
seul message à vous laisser aujourd'hui
ça serait celui-là c'est pour moi le
l'apprentissage majeur de toute ma vie
c'est que les difficultés de la veille
peuvent devenir nos plus grandes fiertés
d'aujourd'hui
alors vous voyez depuis tout à l'heure
je vous raconte plusieurs rejets que
j'ai pu j'ai pu avoir dans ma vie le
rejet scolaire le rejet avec les filles
le rocher un peu sociétal les moqueries
mais il y a un rejet dont je vous ai pas
parlé en fait c'est le rejet qui pour
moi aucun enfant ne devrait avoir à
vivre dans sa vie c'est le rejet d'un de
ses parents
alors moi j'ai vécu le rejet de ma mère
à l'époque qui s'est matérialisée par de
la violence physique par de la violence
psychologique
et au point même que un soir ma mère
dans un de ses grands moments comme je
les appelle alors faut savoir une chose
c'est que ma mère quand même a quand
même des excuses pour ne pas être la
meilleure des mamans c'est à dire
qu'elle a été
abandonnée par ses propres parents elle
a été elle a perdu un enfant de 4 ans ce
qui pour moi est un des plus gros
traumatismes que l'on puisse vivre en
tant qu'être humain mais un soir dans
une dans un de ces grands moments comme
je les appelle elle va me dire la chose
suivante
elle va me dire Dorian si j'avais le
choix je récupérerai l'enfant que j'ai
perdu et je les changerai contre toi
alors certes pour partir avec de la
confiance et de l'estime dans la vie il
y a mieux
je pourrais vous décrire de mille
manières ce que j'ai ressenti ce soir là
mais il y a pour moi une citation qui
reflète à merveille ce que j'ai envie de
vous dire
c'est une citation d'Eli whistle
qui a déclaré pendant un congrès de la
paix que nul n'est autant capable de
gratitude que celui qui a émergé du
royaume des ténèbres
alors si je vous dis ça si si cette
citation elle me touche autant c'est
pour une bonne raison c'est parce que
le soir bon je vous parle il a été très
difficile pour moi à vivre mon royaume
des ténèbres il a tellement été sombre
qu'à ce moment-là j'ai eu des pensées
suicidaires
à l'époque quand j'avais 10 ans à cette
époque je vivais au cinquième étage et
je me suis sincèrement demandé si ça
valait pas mieux je me jette par la
fenêtre pour en finir avec cette douleur
alors je l'ai pas fait j'en ai beaucoup
voulu à ma mère j'en ai beaucoup
souffert mais paradoxalement j'ai une
immense gratitude pour ce qu'elle m'a
dit ce soir là parce que ce soir là en
fait elle m'a doté d'une empathie
extrême et d'une profonde envie de venir
en aide aux autres et je crois pour
finir cette conférence que
ce que j'aurais envie de vous dire c'est
de vous délivrer le message suivant le
message qui dit que
tous ici dans cette salle on a le on a
le pouvoir de décider de faire de nos
difficultés de nos échecs des
opportunités non seulement pour nous
mais aussi pour le monde qui nous
entoure voilà je vous remercie de
m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]